Earlier we learned about styles and
how you can apply them
to an individual view.
If you want to apply it to all the views
in an activity or application,
you can do it by specifying a theme
attribute on the activity or
application tag in the Android manifest.
Now we style the action bar to look
like these visual mocks for the main and
detail activity.
The settings activity is a special case
because it extends from the preference
activity class,
instead of the action bar activity.
So that's going to be
done in the next section.
For both cases here we want
the background color to be this
blue hex color.
We notice that the detail activity
only shows the title, no app icon.
And this button is to go
up to the parent activity.
If you see visual marks
that have the app icon or
a different up button,
they are outdated.
The material design,
this is our new look.
On the other hand,
the main activity shows the logo.
It's a different attribute
than the app icon.
And this was provided in an acid
drop earlier in the lesson, and
it's called ic_logo.
Because of these differences,
we need two separate themes.
We use AppTheme for the detail activity
and ForecastTheme for the main activity.
In material design you can
choose several app colors and
specify them in your theme to
colorize certain UI components
that are controlled by the framework.
For example the framework will use
colorPrimary as a background of your
action bar or your tool bar.
The framework will also
use colorPrimaryDark
as the status bar color.
To customize our app theme, go to
the Styles file in the values folder.
Our AppTheme inherits
from the system Theme for
a Light app because we have a Light
content area with a DarkActionBar.
We specify colorPrimary to
be this sunshine_blue color.
And this will be displayed in
the action bar, also known as app bar.
And then we set the colorPrimaryDark
to be this darker color.
This is going to be
shown in the status bar,
and typically the status bar is
a darker color than the app bar.
Both of these colors are defined in
the colors.xml file as seen here.
Then for the main activity,
we create a ForecastTheme.
We inherit from AppTheme in case
there's more attributes that we want to
add here, and
then we'll inherit them for free.
However, we do override
the actionBarStyle.
This is so that we can set the logo
to point to this drawable file and
also change the displayOptions so
that the logo does appear.
For more information on
the action bar displayOptions,
you can see the list here.
If you run the app now,
there's a shadow below the action
bar that is default behavior.
However, according to our visual
designs, we want the action bar and
the today item with the blue
background to be on the same plane,
meaning we don't want one to
cast a shadow over the other.
As a result we set the action
bar elevation to be zero
if it is in one pane mode.
If it's in two pane mode, then the today
item does not have a special background,
and it's fine if the action
bar casts a shadow.
Go ahead and make these changes
now using the gists provided.